[Music]
welcome to puzzles paradise puzzlers
paradise this is going to be the first
one I think we're going to look at a few
of mr. Garcia's puzzles I don't know if
you guys heard him it is quite a famous
composer and hopefully we will get the
ones the long ones the ones that have 20
to 30 moves those ones are quite quite
fun straightforward very few very few
side lines but a lot of moves to
calculate so you have to kind of
visualize everything in what we're going
to try to visualize as many moves as we
can but this one this first one is a
little bit easier I guess quite
straightforward not a lot of side lines
so think about it for a few minutes try
to understand your candidate moves and
then we're going to go with the main
line why to move yeah I think all of
them if I'm not mistaken is going to be
white to move unless no all of them are
white to move so the first candidate is
probably be sure before sure be sure
before absolutely I think you said
previously Bishop c2 so I mean checks we
should always consider first yeah very
rarely do we see this type of long
studies beginning with checks but Bishop
c2 definitely should be considered the
problem is that after king b5 among
other things yeah we simply cannot do or
cannot continue we don't have any clear
continuation to put more pressure on the
black King that's what we're going to
have to do we're going to have to
somehow find a way to trap the black
King
that's I mean after Bishop before
that's the question what does black do
and the beautiful thing about studies is
that they also have to find defenses so
it trains both your attacking skills and
your defensive skills so give it a shot
he has only one move king b5 is losing
on the spot after so Bishop before King
V 596 discovery Czechia 9686 bishop
takes a 8 and that's it so that's not
good
Queeny eight absolutely well it's it's
easy to get that conclusion Bishop
before threatens that's not the biggest
threat
Bishop c6 is checkmate in one move after
a bishop before right so Bishop before
threatening Bishop c6 also try the Nick
Knight c5 but Bishop c6 just kills the
game on the spot so there's three ways
at least as many as I can count to to
defend against Bishop c6 one is one of
them is queen a6 which is easily refuted
after 95 one of them one of them is king
b5 which we've already seen 96 and the
other one is Queenie 8 I think the last
one stands so let's look at Queenie 8
and I'm going to play the moves all the
way until Queenie 8 because the hard
part only begins now how do you get the
blacking all the way to c6 ok now King
b5 a for now I can go king before for
example or king a6 or b6 in general one
thing that we have to notice is that if
the black King gets to the dark squares
especially b6 if you play four before he
gets away he escapes because we have a
very nice grip on the light squares due
to our Bishop nevertheless the light the
dark squares are quite unstable 96 here
I'm not going to take with the Queen yes
yes and that doesn't change much you can
easily refute it because it just doesn't
change much in the position again I take
with the night I'm now going to take
with the Queen obviously
all right no I cannot take the bishop on
e4 because the bishop on e4 is
indirectly protected if you take only
495 comes all the time the shop c2 was
the right move so we're going to start
with Bishop c2 came to b5 take it all
the way interval yet d6 but then I take
with a punk right so that that square is
his mind
we cannot go under pony for check King
before and I escaped on dark squares
sure I think you're onto something
Bishop to a4 try to calculate that all
the way until the end calculated all the
way into Radian Arjun it's not it's not
finishing immediately try to find that's
the beauty of it try to find blacks
defenses as well
you're not done Arjun I guarantee you're
not done I guarantee you you haven't
found the best defense for black
I'm sure you saw the idea let everybody
try to understand what the idea is after
Bishop before he has to take exactly
Bishop a4 King they say four and now we
go night from g5 to e4 were threatening
what
you're threatening mate in one move with
Knight c3 right so now black has a few
options to defend one of them is king b5
in which case we have Knight d6 and now
we have two Knights fighting for that
square so 96 c2 x d6 90 x d6 and that's
a fork and that endgame is winning let's
just see okay he can go some right and
now it's easy to assess this endgame
because we have already two passers and
this one on h6 is simply a monster yeah
it just keeps in check his night this
night doesn't go anywhere and then were
basically a piece up and he doesn't have
any any threatening passers so this is
easy to assess it's winning for white in
this position though obviously black has
better defenses yes sure
25
and then you do what
[Applause]
exactly so right now we just have to
basically carry away with our plan and
just take on it for attack the Queen
force it to move somewhere it doesn't
have a lot of scores because she has to
stay close to the score on c3 now once
again if you take on e4 I go Knight c5 I
regain my queen and that's a winning
endgame so you have to go Queen d4 is
the only place where you can keep
contact with the score on c3 and now we
just simply continue attacking and
there's nothing there's nothing he can
do if he goes to d3 the problem is there
is another fork yeah and there's no
other squares to defend c3 tonight's
powerful knights and the knight on h8 is
not doing anything so alright that was
the warm-up way to move still mr. Garcia
quite forced but still you have to
calculate around 11 moves there's no
easy ones in this class this is an easy
one you said I mean 96 shirts it's
Bishop III okay that's that's a good
good try for sure and then I take I take
on a six yeah you have to calculate rook
takes 97 King this seven so what he's
saying is 96 King e8
Bishop III rook takes a six check sure
but is this an game of course it's
trapped but are you getting in time okay
show me how
surely I should have played I think if
you got me this one this time yeah I
made a mistake because now you get with
your king all the way down in time so in
this position I think I'm playing a five
now
[Music]
now you can play Bishop 86
and you put your Bishop to a3 and then
you just bring your king so hmm I don't
think so but Bishop III is definitely a
good try let's see why it doesn't win
okay I also have Knight f4 as an idea
potential idea in this position yeah why
don't I try Knight f4
okay
Knight takes Knight I think he wants
actually it works yeah Knight takes
Knight Bishop a7 and you think you beat
me this em game let's see it's
interesting it's actually a very
interesting and I think you have to take
right that's even better
so I'm going to go here now
a seven in the game is over right hey
seven and the pawn promotes so after
Bishop d6 this is just losing or not
let's see is the same game winning how
is the win okay
keep going that's what I'm saying okay
yeah and now if I go away for King c4
and now King before and then you take
with the king and if I go a three here
then you just simply take and I'm not
connected to your part
King the seven you protect and that's
the wind okay so you found some
interesting idea
still I think Knight f4 should be the
refutation oh I I did have another idea
but that shouldn't work for me
let's try to k6 again I have a feeling
somehow you clicked me
ah I think I got it
no I did what I was calculating was a
five King takes here a three and now the
problem is you have this move while
you're threatening Bishop before and if
I go king c5 you go Bishop h6 you can do
that on the other side as well
yeah so you can go Bishop h6 you force
me to go on e7 and then you go on this
side the point being you just have to
reach the a3 of a diagonal if you manage
to get on a3 you're you're winning
from here I'm invited you are yeah right
but it's kind of the same thing though I
think the same idea I'm gonna go Bishop
III yes and now the thing is I think I'm
gonna go this way
oh wait
correct no we all right the first time
we can we can go King D 5 we were
completely right
yeah and now just King B 3 I don't know
why we went a 4 and I don't know why we
stopped here we said king of I said King
a fire and I was like oh it's not it's a
draw what I was what I was thinking was
Bishop c1 here I forgot that we have
King c2 very simple okay yeah so if you
cannot get your Bishop on the f8 a three
diagonal then is just to draw nigh to g1
works as well I think I think Nigel on
I'm not sure does this work because
we're one tempo down now that's the
problem but I think it works as well it
should work yeah yeah it works an IG one
works as well okay so we've seen why
Bishop III doesn't complete the task
maybe we can do something else
Knight d6 is the correct mode 96 is the
correct beginning King to e8 and now you
have to be a bit more precise the idea
is very similar but there's different
ways of achieving the same the same
concept yes
rook takes b7 rook takes d7
the seven first very good the idea is
good you just have to change the move
order so yes these seven first King
takes d7 now we take on b7 he's forced
to take because he cannot defend b8
promotion in any other way and then 95
right and then we go here and now all
right
is it over it's not over
so try to find the best defense for
black now
okay
mm-hmm
gone
kingi for and then cane kingi for I'm
attacking your bishop in the same time
that you attack my knight
if you move the bishop my knight escapes
if you take my knight then I take your
Bishop and your pony zombie too and I
mean I'm in control yeah I'm going to
catch your point maybe you have to
adjust your variation along the way not
saying it's wrong I'm not saying it's
wrong
but maybe you can find a better move
along the way but that's black to move
after Bishop III Bishop III was the last
move so king c6 is obviously a step in
the right direction
King d5
this is the same thing if you go King
age five working at five and then to g4
does the same thing oh yeah oh yeah yeah
if you can me yeah if he gets to the big
porn then he's going to be perfectly
fine before king c4 Knight of - my
knight escapes Knight goes to d3 you
cannot take my night because you're
before pawn is having so I'm gonna go
king c6 king of six king the same thing
king d5 my plan as black is to attack
your pawn force you to defend it with
your bishop and then just move my knight
now okay you're onto something
and now pawn b3 yeah we're kick we're
keeping him out is it over no so find
the best defense for black to be honest
it's kind of forced he doesn't have a
lot of ways of trying to defend yes
Arjun king c6 of course how to continue
after that
King b5
King before and how is that position the
knight is trapped that's a win that's a
win we don't have to take the knight
very good hmm very good yeah King c6 and
now King g4 would be a terrible blunder
going for the material because after
night king b5 if you take the night I go
king before draw and if you try to
defend this square with Bishop D to
defend the the entry then I just simply
go night f2 my knight escapes easy draw
so after king c6 you have to understand
that this night doesn't really amount
much all I have to do is just defend
this pawn so now I'm going to go back
king b5 and I'm right in time to defend
the pawn and this is easy with we're
just simply going to take the King all
the way down to b8 and then we're going
to checkmate him with the bishop well
actually not necessarily checkmate but
just actually yes checkmate we can go
something like this
the knight can never move yeah
and I think the easier ways to put him
into into children now the Night Moves
and then we go Bishop f4 checkmate yeah
I mean we have plenty of ways to do it
we can play Bishop e5 and then Bishop d4
and then Bishop e5 and then just promote
but I think in b6 is just nicer so it's
easy win okay good job good job guys
and let's go to the 20 something 28
moves that's it that's all
we'll take it step by step
28 moves to win Queen takes pawn good
job
you found the first move King takes a
three by force if you go king b1 it's
losing on the spot Queen b3 queen bee -
Queen takes B - game over yeah so King
takes a three Queen III check you see
you're on the right track
now it's now it's probably going to be a
little bit more difficult to choose
blacks best defense we're going to have
to take them one by one King a force
should be losing let's see how Bishop c6
King before
Quincy v King b3 mm-hmm that's that's
transposing to the main line so keep
going
King before King b3 Bishop d5 King bee
to only move because if I go King a for
Quincy for King a3 Queen b3 so let's get
there now if he goes King a for Quincy
for King a3 Queen b3 checkmate
so he has to go came to be to only move
no no we have to find a way to keep the
checks going because if he manages to
defend then were just a lot of material
down yeah he means one move he needs to
get his King to safety and that's it
game over sure let's continue King be
won only move otherwise you lose your
queen Queen or d3
okay King c-123 King Siwon
so after king b1 maybe we should do
something else try to think logically
what you could potentially be getting
along the way maybe what you could be
capturing along the way with checks if
you take my night and you leave any I
mean it doesn't matter actually you
don't have to leave any point on the
board does just going to be a draw or
worse if you leave too many points then
you might be losing but yeah Queen Queen
and Bishop versus queen is not a win
it's a drop yes Arjun in this position
I'm gonna go King Sidney King D - nope
Queen d2 in default while actually Queen
D for King be one Queen d1 King be too
windy too sure
I think I think MB one is a little bit
better will take on a five and we'll see
what happens after that
but let's all wanna go king b1 I want to
know I don't want to go King III King
III is the worst defense is the yeah
worse defense
so Quincy for king b1 now I'm gonna go
here what do you do know I don't know
you tell me what what the difference is
it's a good question though
what the difference is you should ask
that yourself and then you'll find the
answer what he was saying was actually
quite quite accurate so he was starting
with Queenie one the idea is to keep the
king next to the Queen by force and in
the meantime start farming for your
pawns but the question is why why would
I want to take that the f5 point does it
matter well imagine this position
without the f5 point you play Bishop
before and it's a checkmate in one move
yeah so now now you have kind of a
logical idea behind whatever you've been
doing for the past 20 moves so we go
Queen e1 yeah 25 we've already said that
he's forced to go King b1 take the pawn
now I'm gonna go King's you wanna check
again now I'm gonna go King B - well
which one so again it's a question
pretty sure one of them doesn't work its
Queen Queen b5 or Queen e2
try to make that decision for yourself
Quinny one of course Oh anyone know I
mean we'll keep on checking we cannot
allow him to start checking us yeah
don't allow him to start checking us
because that's at least a draw after
Bishop before I have a feeling we might
be losing because he has so many extra
pawns right so Queenie one has to be
played King b2 Queen d2 absolutely and
now we got the same position but there's
no more no more pawn on f5 right
so King b1 is no longer an option
I have to go King a3 so right now
finally we got him where we want to now
we have to calculate once again let's
finish him off with precise play there
are still 12 moves to go so it's not
over yet now I think after Queen takes a
5 which is the right move King b2 quindi
talking a 3 so we got the same position
but forget about the pawn on e5 is no
longer on the board all right let's put
it on board King c5 Queen g1
Queen b6 thank you draw actually maybe I
want to play I think I want to play I
think I want to play for a win
it's it's it's been logical all along
guys continue on the same logic that's
where we came from Queen King to be to
know it's the same thing we already had
this position so we can repeat it if we
want but it's not gonna help us
you can repeat to again sometime if your
wife I doubt you will find yourself in
such a position ever but Queen were 23
King to be for I want to escape
Quincy for ah you tricked me
did you trick me you might have yes you
did trick me because now if I go King a5
you do what
so King before it was my mistake is now
after King a5
so King before Queen C for King a5 Queen
C 5 and now I have to go on a 6 if I go
on a 4 then Queen takes a 7 and that's
just winning the Queen King b2 king c1 I
was a bit too adventurous with with my
king
so I'm going to stay next to my queen
well we have to do something else we
have to take that pawn from home from a
7 we've been taking all the possible
points let's try to find a way to get
that pawn by force
Queen III king b2 Queen D for King b1
Bishop a4 King a 2 now we got the pawn
Quintus a7 yeah all right we got there
stage number I don't remember
stage number we got all the important
points continue this is the main line I
don't I'm not gonna start from the
beginning this is move 20-something
continue
now you have to ask yourself what why in
the world did we take the pawn on May 7
why did we take that pawn you are on the
right track
Queen 2d for King a to wish of d5 King
b1
you've had that position before the only
difference was that you had upon on a
seven and a pawn on e5
now it's minus two pawns King be too
windy one King be two we can put him
once again in that key position with the
King on a three and the Queen on D -
this is the key position now what's the
difference
weed out the pawn on a seven with the
pot without the pawn on a seven or a
five king c5 okay interesting idea was
the difference correct
king c5 queen g1 king b5 now with the
pawn on a seven he would have had Queen
b6 check right now he doesn't Queen
before his a is a checkmating threat and
there is not really a good way to defend
against it we can go here but then the
King hides and now he can safely resign
that's it the whole mechanism was just
to find the right way to check the King
in order to like take all the pawns on
the way and then return to the key
position correct
so that was mr. Garcia torture 601 class
is over guys alright alright thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]